ce dimanche se déroulera l'élection de
la législative partielle sur la deuxième
circonscription des Yvelines notre
candidat Pascal Thévenot portera les
couleurs de la droite et du centre les
couleurs des républicains pour cette
élection extrêmement importante sur
laquelle je voudrais vous dire quelques
mots d'abord parceque nous le
connaissons bien l'Assemblée nationale
il a été un des nôtres lors de la
précédente législature nous connaissons
son sérieux l'attachement à son
territoire et la volonté de le défendre
sur le plan politique il est évident que
une victoire dans cette circonscription
serait un signal puissant donné à la
majorité présidentielle dont on voit
bien que les difficultés importantes que
connaît notre pays sont en panne de
solutions proposées par le gouvernement
et par le Président de la République
donc chers amis un choix
utile le bon choix c'est Pascal Thévenot
dimanche prochain
[Musique]